accompagner et ému comme il se doit un
jour de rentrée impressionné aussi mais
puissance 19
comme le virus en la confiance quoi mais
on est stressé c'est logique en fait
voilà comment je sais que l écoute pas
vraiment la maison les s2 barria tout ça
donc c'est que je risque quand même
wesh pas tranquille dans la cour le
soulagement est pourtant palpable malgré
la rubalise malgré les distances
l'école qui reprend c'est la vie sociale
qui refleurit même si on doit faire une
croix sur la partie de foot c'est déjà
mieux temps un coup de fil de voir
certes il faut prendre de nouvelles
marques conformes à celles qui sont au
sol on désinfecte ou ne partage pas mais
surtout on se remet dans le bain en tout
cas je vous félicite parce que vous avez
été plutôt très très serré du des
retours systématiquement donc voilà
est-ce que c'est une un type de
scolarité qui vous conviendrait ça
toujours être sens non même quand on
revenir
oui ça me manquait donc bah déjà la
maîtresse puis les devoirs à la maison
c'est pas facile c'est pas ton je pense
au niveau des acquisitions d
apprentissage c'est plus le rythme va
falloir un petit peu de temps pour que
les enfants se reprennent ce rythme de
travail au niveau des réel apprentissage
des objectifs je pense que voilà chaque
équipe pédagogique les collèges vont
être conscient et reprendre les enfants
là où ils en sont cas d'école la reprise
c'est aussi la séance de travaux
pratiques des grands une répétition
générale pour les élus qui ont choisi de
rouvrir leur établissement
la vraie difficulté le vrai défi vert
d'accueillir déjà le 18 mai pratiquement
le triple d'enfants monte à plus de 300
et surtout imaginer le 2 juin
parce que le 2 juin on s'attend à avoir
une très forte progression des enfants
présents et l'on pourra dire si on est
capable de faire ou pas parce que pour
l'instant deux élèves sur 10 en moyenne
sont du bon côté de la barrière